each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
hi everybody so I'm going to be talking
about this this thing that I thought
would be very you know interesting and
timely which is how we manage to take a
piece a large piece of legacy software
and make it run twice as fast on a quad
core before I get into that I thought I
would just provide a little context for
where this project fits in with the
other research that I've done so the
initial projects that I did in my group
were focused on performance things in
particular how do we extract thread
level parallelism in fact that's what
this talk is about today and the other
thing we worked on was how do we do how
do we make better use of caches and so
I've given talks about having having
worked on these both of these things
generically we then focus specifically
on how to do it for databases how we
redesign databases that make better use
of caches and that's something I get him
talks about here at Microsoft in the
past so should mention was one of my
students and he was a Microsoft fellow
and a Microsoft intern and all that
stuff today I'm actually working on two
projects so the first is we call log
based architectures where the goal is to
detect and fix software bugs on
production systems without slowing down
the application so i gave a talk on this
project the last time I was up here
about a year and a half ago and I'm
hoping to come back sometime in the next
couple months and give you an update on
some more results that we have on this
project finally I'm working on this sort
of far-out science fiction sounding
project that I'll be happy to talk to
you about after the talk if you're
curious what we want to physically
render moving objects and build the
holodeck okay but what I'm talking about
today is the sort of capstone of a
project that we did at CMU that we
called Stampede and this was really
Chris kala hands PhD thesis work this is
the first time that I've given a talk
that's not on something that we're
actively working on this moment so this
is something we completed a couple years
ago but the reason why I'm talking about
now is I never happen to have never
talked about it here at Microsoft and I
think it's also very relevant today with
multi-core and people trying to paralyze
software so also it's very timely
because people at hardware companies are
making decisions right now about
including the hardware support that I'll
be talking about so if people from say
Microsoft that support was interesting
that might affect the world so the
starting point for this is multi-core so
today we have quad cores and the
projection is that we'll have more and
more cores over time so we can't crank
up clock rates anymore but we can stamp
out more and more processors on a chip
so clearly if you're interested in
increasing throughput there are more
cores to run things on it's good for
that but what about simply making things
run faster so one view of the world is
don't worry everything will be fine with
multi-core because from now on everyone
will write parallel software and it all
speed up perfectly so that's an
optimistic view be great if that was
true but I've spent you know 14 plus
years teaching parallel people how to a
parallel software and the empirical data
it suggests that it's difficult to do
that to make it both correct and fast so
hopefully people will get much better at
this but that is that's a challenging
thing to do we don't expect that to be
fixed overnight and there's also this
issue of legacy software so what about
things that are important that have
already been written that aren't
parallel or what about pieces of things
that maybe they have been paralyzed but
they're important parts that haven't
been paralyzed yet so that's actually
what I'll discuss today so another sort
of rosy view of the world is don't worry
multi-core is fine because we'll have
these fancy compilers that will
automatically paralyzed everything and
it so it all speed up perfectly so I've
actually worked on projects before we
were trying to do this and that was the
original motivation of the thing I'm
talking about today it's very difficult
for compilers to do that other
them for sort of scientific programs
where the dependences are very
straightforward to think about this is
very difficult in particular ambiguous
data dependences are a major stumbling
block for the compiler to try to do this
type of thing so this motivated us at
yep question I often hear which is oh
don't worry you know these chips are
really is for web servers and everything
is inherently divided up into so many
little chunks that we can keep these for
is busy or the users running so many
processes that we're going to keep these
Porsche busy well fortunately there are
enough of those things around already
that are interesting that there will be
some immediate value to having these
processors but I think that over time
it'll be nice to have more and more
things taking advantage of them and not
just the sort of embarrassingly parallel
workloads but but fortunately there are
embarrassingly parallel workloads so
that gives us a something that's ready
to go on all these these processors so
our motivation was what do you do about
those other things though what about the
things that you care about that aren't
embarrassingly parallel that those
things do exist so the idea behind our
this proud our stampedes CMU was we
wanted to have a new through combination
of hardware and compiler support we want
to create this capability that you could
optimistically run things in parallel
without knowing for sure whether that
was safe and several other groups like
it you know Illinois Stanford Wisconsin
in other places i've looked at similar
ideas and the idea is you create the
threads you hope that there aren't
dependences but the hardware will
monitor whether there really are and if
there are things will roll back so it's
a little bit like a transaction people
have been talking a lot about
transactional memory but the difference
is that with transactions you already
have concurrent threads and you're just
trying to get them to not trample each
other data structures here while we
start off with sequential execution and
we know the order in which everything
should occur so if there's any conflict
between two things you know which which
one is supposed to win it's the one
that's supposed to have executed earlier
but there's actually a lot of similarity
in terms of the hardware to me
the stuff work so our initial motivation
was the previous slide which is we're
going to automatically paralyzed
everything in the world and it'll all
speed up nicely so we did use this
support to paralyze the spec integer
benchmarks and we found that they did
run about twenty thirty five percent
faster which is actually respectable for
if you compare that with typical
architectural optimizations you know
most usually an architectural idea is
successful if you get say ten percent
improvement so compared to that it's not
too bad but it's not exactly the linear
speed-up you're hoping for so what I'm
talking about today is something
different which is rather than this
fully automatic approach we're looking
at first of all a much larger and more
interesting piece of software we're
looking at Berkeley DB which is a
database or part of a database and
rather than doing something fully
automatic we're doing something semi
automatic so the programmer actually is
involved there's this iterative process
that I'll talk about where the system
tries something it doesn't work very
well gives feedback to the programmer
they make a decision to tweak something
small and they go back and try again and
I think that this approach is actually
extremely promising and you'll see that
it actually worked quite well in this
case so this is what I want people to
hear about this this semi automatic
approach so the application that we're
looking at it is a berkeley DB so it's a
database engine now databases are
already run in parallel what we're
trying to do here is run them in
parallel in a new way which is we want
to take individual transactions and
break them into parallel and split them
into parallel chunks the way that you
typically get parallelism is you you get
parallelism across separate transactions
we're still doing that but we wanted
even more parallelism than that so we're
breaking them up now the reason why I
think this is interesting beyond
databases is really you can just think
of this as an example of a big
complicated piece of software where the
thing that we're trying to paralyze was
not written with
parallelism in mind in fact it was
written under the explicit assumption
that you would never try to run pieces
of it in parallel within a given
transaction it's not safe to do that at
all so if you try to actually sit down
and rewrite the code so that you could
exploit intro transaction parallelism
this would take a very long time and be
very painful you'd have to understand
very large amount of the code it would
probably take years of effort I think to
do that I think you'd actually really
have to start over almost from scratch
with a lot of fundamental structures so
okay so but we're not going to do that
all right so switching into this that's
so now we're going to dive into Berkeley
DB and talk a little bit about
transactions in particular so here's my
student Chris who did the work I guess
this is his idea of what the database
users look like so we've got our cave
men here who are writing their sequel
code and launch sending it into this
database server so here come their
transactions and then what happens is
we've got this you know sequel server
big DBMS sitting here and the actual
data stored and how are we going to get
proof performance well today what
happens is separate transactions get to
run in parallel on different cores and
that's we get throughput from that and
that's good for performance now why do
we want to make transactions run faster
well first of all people do care about
latency so if it takes too long to run
my transaction I get annoyed and also if
one of the transactions is grabbing a
lock that prevents other transactions
that need the same lock from executing
so that actually does hurt throughput so
what can we do about transaction latency
so if you look at tpc see so this is a
benchmark for transaction processing the
most the transaction within CPCC that
takes up the most time is something
called new order so you're placing a new
order and here's a pseudocode version of
that of that transaction so and you're
basically
you've got a basket of items and you're
going to update the stock information
for all those items so here is a no one
query within it we're going to do this
select and one thing that you can do the
database is do today is try to extract
parallelism within a particular query so
I can take this select and break it
across multiple processors now this idea
works really well for decision support
so if i'm launching queries that are
going to take a long time that i can get
some really nice performance out of this
but unfortunately for transaction
processing these queries tend to be very
short-lived they don't run for very long
so i don't get a whole lot of
performance this way okay so that's not
so great what I prefer to do is actually
get parallelism across separate queries
or within one transaction so for example
I could take different iterations of
this loop and try to run those
iterations in parallel so let that
sounds good but this doesn't work this
would break Berkeley DB and probably a
lot of other systems because they're not
written with this in mind none of the
internal structures like locks and
latches and all those things are set up
to work this way so but as you'll see in
this talk the safety net of thread level
speculation makes it much easier to to
fix this problem so let me talk just
briefly about thread level speculation
and how that works so if you imagine
some original thread so this this thing
is executing in time and when we try to
run it in parallel what we're really
doing is taking something that was
supposed to occur later and we're
running it concurrently with this
logically earlier chunk of work and
we're dereferencing pointers so the
thing that can go wrong oh and we want
to label all these with some logical
timestamp and the system does that
automatically so we realized that this
one is supposed to occur before this one
okay but sometimes bad things happen so
for example we loaded we do a load from
a particular address and we loaded it
before was stored over here so we saw
the wrong value and the same thing
happened here so this is bad
because that's not possible so what
happens is the hardware detects this
notice is that this bad thing happened
it squashes the thread and then restarts
it and the second time through good
things happen so now the data
dependences get forwarded correctly and
it works so what we see is we we use
these logical timestamps that we call
epochs to a number of the different
threads and the hardware is going to
detect problems and restart things and
this is a little bit like recovering
from a transaction like I mentioned
before yep Muslim do not have dead
dependencies between iteration well they
haven't they'll have that a piece of
integration iteration dead abusive
iterations don't exist free offers from
itls that's benefit that's a really good
question and the next couple slides are
going to dive into that because that's
that actually is the answer to that is I
think is very interesting so so hold
that thought for one second so but the
idea with the mechanism is hope the idea
is hopefully in the worst case we run
about as fast as sequential execution
not actually we run a little bit slower
than that because there are some
overheads and in the best case if there
are no dependencies we get full
parallelism and great speed up so but
the key thing is data dependences so how
often do these dependences exist now
this is going to start addressing its
question here so on the motivation for
this hardware support was actually spec
integer type of program so little things
where we have relatively small threads
from loops and in those cases
dependences tend to be fairly infrequent
and the threads tend to be relatively
small so if it's painful to recover from
speculation failing somewhere it's not
that big of a deal because most of the
time there aren't any problems but when
we look at databases when we look at
transactions of paralyzing them the
threads are much larger they're
typically these are maybe hundreds or
maybe a thousand or so instructions and
these are tens and maybe even hundreds
of thousands of instructions here in
these things
and there are many dependencies there
are typically dozens of real dynamic
dependencies between these threads so we
see in contrast to the easier case we
have we have lots of dependences so we
can't it's not okay if we only win when
there are no dependences will never win
they oh they're always there so we have
to find a way to tolerate dependencies
I'll talk about that so we actually
learned something new about how to
design the system from doing this and we
also have to tell we have to have much
more buffering to store these larger
threads and in the second part of the
talk i'll discuss how we address those
things we also have concurrent
transactions that we're speculative aryl
izing so that has to work and there's a
nice way to make that work too okay so
there are a lot of dependences but
there's some good news here which is the
hardware is already tracking dependences
it has to do that to realize when it
needs to restart things and the
information that it's capturing happens
to be exactly what you'd like to know if
you were going to fix a problem so it
knows ah that didn't work because of
this particular load and store pair so
the idea is when you see a problem you
can actually give feedback to the user
and say ah that's the immediate problem
right there this the speculation failed
because of this and if you can fix that
then you'll get to see the next one and
then the next one and the next one so
you can if you choose to and this is
what we did in this study you can
incrementally fix dependence by
dependence and you don't you don't have
to make them all go away it's just each
time you do it you might see slightly
better and slightly better for formats
so that's that's the idea okay now
there's one non intuitive thing that
could happen which is sometimes
eliminating a dependence can make things
worse so in this case we have on the
Left we have this original case where
there's a dependence between P and Q and
P triggers a problem first so if we
eliminate the problem with P and now Q
triggers the restart we actually restart
later
it's longer to realize that there's a
problem and we actually have worse
performance so that's that's annoying so
one of the things that we did is we fix
this and really the fundamental problem
is having to get an all-or-nothing
having all or nothing as the mode of
execution isn't so nice so to fix that
one of the new things that we modified
in the system is we essentially added a
extremely super lightweight
checkpointing mechanism where we can we
can keep these different checkpoints
such that if something goes wrong we
only have to back up to the most recent
checkpoint we don't have to go all the
way back to the beginning of a thread
and that was really important for making
any of this work i'll show you numbers
on that later so now we have a better a
more robust system design that will talk
that will work much better because of
this okay so and the this was a critical
to getting these relative speed up from
having this was really important we work
with this support we could get speed ups
of around 1.9 to 2.9 okay so yeah sure
mmm so cute dude
synchronize the frequent check points
across threads because you can certainly
have a case where the thread on the Left
months behind and it's up conflicting
with something previous sub thread so Oh
multiple of these things yep I do have
some backup slides on that but basically
we do have this issue where you have the
whole chain of things that you have to
cancel on if that's what you're asking
about so we do have a way to we do have
a way to we can selectively roll back to
the most recent checkpoint in each of
the threads if we have a chain of things
that we have to cancel what's all that
ah so what we do is a we're lazy about
rolling back threads so we don't roll
them back aggressively so we will only
roll back once if at all we want we
don't roll back multiple times because
you could imagine discovering more and
more dependences and eventually rolling
old thing back so we didn't do it
aggressively we did it lazily it's only
one we would commit a thread that we
would we only triggered it commits time
so this picture it looks a little funny
this isn't actually quite accurate it
doesn't happen at the moment that this
occurs it actually happens a little
later right now I assume that I was your
collective a violation could roll me
back three of the checkpoints on the
right hand side oh I see yes yes yes so
you have to get Bobby I'm get back to
any number of them yes yep okay great we
we recognize so in this picture what is
trying to show is that you actually it's
hard to see but we actually rolled back
to this checkpoint this load was above
this checkpoint it's right here here's
the checkpoint so we actually skip this
one and went back to this one so we we
know which checkpoint is the most recent
one ahead of you okay
yes it and actually you later but it's a
it's like a it's a trivially trivial
mechanism for checkpointing that works
only because we're already supporting
thread level speculation but we just
bump a counter somewhere that's all we
do okay so to make all of this work
there are different layers here there
are transactions running on top of a
DBMS running on top of a system there's
an operating system in here too of
course but yeah it's an operating
systems confident i forgot to mention
the operating system okay i'll be shown
to the door now okay so in particular
what we're running is TPC see as our
transactions on top of berkeley DB
because we had the code to it on top of
a simulated machine we'd like to run it
on a real machine but the hardware
support didn't exist so now this
involves different people changing what
they're doing a little bit so the
transaction programmer we don't want
them to change anything that they're
doing if they choose to they can
explicitly indicate where they want to
break their transactions into different
threads in our experiments we simply
took every loop in a transaction and ran
loop iterations in parallel and they
didn't need to do anything to to do that
so we don't this is there are a lot of
people who do this so we don't want them
to have we don't want to put any of the
burden on them there's a lot more
interesting stuff that happens in for
database developers so they do have to
change things and that's actually most
of what the talk is about is how we fix
that now that was the part that took a
month so there's more work to do here
than here but this still isn't a lot of
work and then there is some work for
hardware people to do which is to put
this into the hardware and that's been
sort of very well studied and right now
it's just a value proposition argument
that people are actively debating right
now you say pls our research
mostly done are there new capabilities
that might pop out I realized start to
create the feature that you've worked in
the area along time so I don't think
anyone's really actively pushing on it
right now or I think it's mostly cool
down at the moment but it could become
interesting again I'm actually yeah so
for the moment it's it's paused I think
the UGC significant unsolved problems
from meaning from the TLS limitation
side now or it's basically most problems
are solved if you just find the right
set of stuff from higher layers then
we'll it'll take off yeah it the reason
why it's not in today's hardware is not
because designers don't think that
there's some major problem that would
prevent them from implementing it it's
just because they haven't been convinced
yet that people want it but they know
how to design it though I've seen you
know many different designs at all seem
reasonable so people aren't worried
about whether it'll work just whether
they should bother to do it I think once
it really exists in Hardware it'll
probably make the research interesting
again potentially because they'll be
much more interesting software built
around it and then that might make life
interesting again okay so in turn from
if you're say looking at the world from
a database perspective the thing that's
new and interesting is we have a way to
extract parallelism within a transaction
without actually changing the
transactions with only small changes to
the database management system we don't
have to change anything about locking we
didn't introduce any bugs and we got
nice performance we made transactions
run twice as fast on on four cores okay
so here's an outline of the rest of the
talk so there are really two parts to
this the first part i'm going to talk
about how the database changed our how
the database layer is changed to take
advantage of thread level speculation
and then i'll briefly talk a bit about
the hardware support so these are the
new things we learn by doing this as
opposed to spec benchmarks oh but the
first part is the transaction programmer
so we have to divide the transactions
into
threads so looking at new order again it
has this loop and if you look at this
loop it takes up so new order is the
most important transaction and this loop
takes up about eighty percent of the
time in the transaction so this is the
hot spot and if we can make this run in
parallel that's a good thing to do and
in fact if you focus on the code it
looks like this is almost embarrassingly
parallel while almost not quite so it's
possible that different iterations will
depend on each other if the same item
appears multiple times as separate
entries in the in the list that's
possible for the benchmark it turns out
that the definition given the way we
configured it is that this will happen
once every hundred thousand times so
this looks like a great opportunity for
thread level speculation because will
only fail once at every hundred thousand
times so at this level it looks very
good so all that you need to do is
decide that you want to run this
parallel this loop in parallel and the
programmer can either explicitly
annotate that or not or you could just
have the system decide to do that so
there's not much work for the
transaction programmer to do and that's
good okay the next part is what about
the database developers how do we remove
problems from the database management
system so what we'll see is in fact just
simply doing this didn't work very well
at all there were a lot of problems and
they would didn't occur at the sequel
level they occurred inside of the
database itself okay so I had this
picture before where I showed that what
happens is we try to run things in
parallel and they don't run very well in
parallel because there really are a lot
of dependencies so what we're going to
do is use the hardware support allows us
gives this profiling feedback where we
can tell exactly what the pieces of our
code were that caused this most critical
dependence then we can do hopefully a
small simple thing to fix it we get a
little bit better performance and a
little bit better and so on so that's
the idea yeah
servation that transaction memory will
still have a virginal concordance
in a way explicitly paralyzed by the
program rumors here starting with legacy
code but nevertheless available today
seems like you are going to make
modifications to existing applications
so it seems like a natural comparison
would be to take the stand base and try
to paralyze it using its actual software
partner that's a good question so I
think it was a amount of effort to take
this and ok so it does i think there's a
very big difference in terms of the
amount of effort involved because
transactional memory the starting point
is that you already have a concurrent
program and and that it's mostly you
know it's correct and you're just trying
to take you know a critical section and
get better performance out of it that's
an important thing to do but you're
starting with something that's already
concurrent in this case we're starting
with something that's sequential and
we're only we're not ever we never get
to the point where we really have a
properly threaded program instead we're
just fixing some we're relaxing some
aspect of the program and in making it a
little more parallel but we're not
bothering to fix all the other things in
the thread so that if I didn't do the
actual study of trying to rewrite
berkeley DB where we would rewrite the
threads but as i said before i think
that that involves almost starting from
scratch in terms of writing the code
it's a really fundamental assumption
throughout the software that there are
never multiple threads within one
transaction and i think that would be
measured in years of effort not amount
of effort to do that so a transactional
memory is a good thing but it's it's a
for a different purpose than this ok so
what I'm going to do now is talk about
one concrete example of something that
we up case where we found a problem and
fixed it just to illustrate the types of
things we found here so one important
part of the database is the buffer pool
manager so this is a little bit like the
virtual memory system of the database
when we access data so the buffer pool
is the section of physical memory if you
access something that's on disk you say
get page in berkeley DB and a gray
something off the disk puts it into
memory and then to make sure that it
doesn't get displaced until you finished
it bumps a reference counter so we
realized somebody's actively using this
then you get to access it and when
you're finished to release it you say
put page that decrement the reference
count and now that page can be reclaimed
by the buffer pool manager if you need
more physical memory okay so what
happens when we try to run the code in
parallel and looking at these two
primitives so let's say that two
different so we're originally going to
run this thread and then this thread is
supposed to run after it in the original
program and we're optimistically running
them concurrently and they both want to
access page five so they do a get page
they do some work and then they do a put
page it turns out that speculation will
always fail here and the reason is
because of this reference counter so
when we decrement the reference count
here that's going to cause the reference
count value that we read here to look
like it was wrong because it just
changed and we read an older value so
it'll squash speculation and this will
never succeed but if you stop and think
about it for a minute that's not really
this that's a little although that is
strictly what the sequential execution
would have done we don't really need to
behave that way we want buffer pool
management to work but we don't care
about this artifact here so I don't
really care in particular I don't care
which of these pages grab with which of
these threads grab the page first I just
want to make sure that they have it
pinned and memory the right way when
they access it so what we can do in this
case to fix this is we can temporarily
turn off the speculation tracking
mechanism we can say we're about to do
something and we don't want you to treat
this as something that's a problem so
we're going to go ahead and change the
reference count in order for this to be
okay we have to realize it's possible
this thread may get squash for another
reason and if that happens we have to
have a way to undo the side effect that
we just did so fortunately that's easy
to do in this case
to undo a get page all we have to do is
decrement the counter and everything
will be fine so what we do is we escape
speculation we do the operation we store
an undo function and then we turn
speculation back on again yeah age
freshly decrement the counter that
gauging yeah guys I meant I'm in
call fib so okay so to show you
intellectual code here's what we did so
we implemented this again by hand this
isn't automatic the Chris decided that
this was the thing to do so we put a
wrapper function around get page in the
middle of it it calls get page with this
ID that we pass in in addition you know
as I mentioned we turn off speculation
so we have a instruction door hardware
that says turn off speculation don't
track it and then we turn it back on
here we also do some extra checking of
the arguments to make sure that they're
okay because when you're running
spectively you may get a bad ID and we
want to make sure we don't do anything
bad inside this routine but so we do
some extra checking here also we don't
know how to do multiple get pages
concurrently without thread level
speculation turned on so we also add a
mutex to make sure that there's only one
active call to get page at a time and
then finally we say that the way that
you undo this is you need to call put
page in order to undo get page and this
works because the effects here are are
isolated it's not going to cause a
cascading chain of aborts if we do this
we have a way to undo all of our side
effects and this can be used for other
things like memory cursor management or
Malik for example yep problems at the
operating system
so these schedules one of the thirds in
this speculative team yes so we don't
want that I mean well the problem is
that the nothing crashes and burns I
mean well what happens is speculation
will fail that's actually really the
only thing that goes wrong I think we
want it to be things to be gang
scheduled if you want it to work in
general if you have a parallel
application you swap out one of the
threads unpleasant things can happen
like if you're holding a lock hopeless
univ of your viewer schedule yes well
okay what happens is we have a limited
ability to tech conflicts but once thing
if things ever get knocked out of the
cash then we just say there's conflicts
so our default is we squash everything
so we can always fall back to that
that's the reason why it still works the
operating system reclaim something it's
not fast anymore but it's functional
okay so we know how to fix the problem
with get page which we just described
now what about put page so here we are
decrementing the reference count so can
we play the same trick here we can't
because get page is not a weight is not
a proper way to undo you can't undo put
page with get page it may end up going
somewhere else and this could this could
cause very different behavior so instead
what we do is we just postpone doing the
put page until the thread receives this
token that says you are no longer
speculative because everyone ahead of
you is already committed and it's
definitely safe to do that now the
downside is we're actually increasing
the lifetime in which this is pinned in
memory but that's a trade-off that
seemed okay because we're only
increasing it like by a couple thousand
instructions maybe or tens of thousands
of instructions and memories large so
we're not too worried about that in this
case so if we do these two things we can
now actually run code with get pages and
put pages in parallel and that won't
cause speculation to fail
so this is one example of the type of
thing that we are doing ok so in general
delaying something until the end of the
epoch when you're not specula vis
another trick so Chris went through as I
said you know in the title of the talk
he spend a month's worth of effort going
through this process of finding
something fixing something finding the
next thing and fixing it and the other
thing I forgot to mention is that Chris
had never seen Berkeley DB before he
started doing this and he doesn't know
much about databases he's a systems guy
not a database guy never took a database
course or anything like that so to him
this was just a big giant piece of
software that he didn't understand and
but he of all the fixes that he made
they basically fell into three buckets
we saw the two things that we just saw
escaping speculation which you saw for
get page delaying an operation which we
saw for put page and then the other
bucket was there were several cases
where there was a central structure and
the solution was simply to distribute
have a parallel version of it across the
different cores for things like say
gathering statistics you could gather
local statistics and then just add them
together later rather than having one
counter that's one simple example here
so these are the things that we would
that he did okay so now I'm going to
show you some performance results here
so we simulated a quad-core processor it
was a out-of-order superscalar we here's
the memory hierarchy that we were
modeling we were running TPC see in core
we weren't worried about disk accesses
and yeah so we're and we're also
measuring the latency of a transaction
not its throughput ok so here are
results so first I'm showing you the
original unmodified version of the
application running on one core on a
quad core so that means three the cores
are doing nothing because it's a
sequential program sequential piece of
software at least one transaction is so
the way this is color-coded is that
black means that there's a CPU that's
doing nothing
so if three of the processors this is
renormalized execution time are sitting
idle and over the one processor that's
busy the blue part is the time when it's
doing useful work and the green part is
a time when its stall for data cache for
cache misses okay so now we've got this
wonderful thread level speculation
mechanism that we spent years developing
and we turned it on and paralyze this
embarrassingly parallel sequel loop and
we gotta slow down so things were worse
than they were originally by a little
bit about you know eight or so percent
and this is without any of the
optimizations that I just mentioned and
the reason is that the speculation is
always failing so the red part is time
when you've done work that you have to
throw away because it wasn't useful it's
a little bit worse in part because the
cache miss time actually went up a
little bit because previously all of the
data was on one coors cash and now we've
spread it across all the cores so
sometimes our cache misses are more
expensive because we have to go get data
from other cores caches so we lose a bit
here so then Chris started going through
this process of iteratively fixing
things oh okay Oh so first he fixed a
problem with the latches and things
actually got even a little bit worse and
he fixed the problem with locks and
we're still not speeding up and then he
fixed the problem with malloc and free
and things are still not good and then
he fixed the problem with the buffer
pool and suddenly we saw a nice jump in
performance so more than a quarter of
the latency disappeared now you might
wonder well why do you bother to do the
first three things why don't you just
jump to that fourth step and the answer
is you actually had to do all of them
they were you know for problems lurking
right underneath each other and when you
eliminated all of them we saw this
improvement and then he kept going did
something with the cursors error
checking fixed some false sharing fix
something Abby trees and logging and we
eventually got down to almost a two fold
nearly a two fold speed up here so yep
or all of the piece o the G having to
keep adding I ice cube that are all
necessary to get close to that final
performance and then he said that they
they were all working but every single
one of the important yes so the way we
get the feedback is that the hardware
always tells us the most critical one so
if we didn't fix that one it wouldn't
matter if we fixed anything else
underneath that what might matter if we
eventually fix the critical one but
until you fix the critical one you won't
see any improvement oh well these last
two didn't really improve any upon this
one's if that's what you're asking we
didn't we didn't really need to go all
the way out to this point like once we
got to that point kind of leveled on
Paul sure mm-hmm your optimization do
fine No okay so all I mean you wouldn't
do any better than that I mean if you
wanted to stop here fixing these things
without fixing that would not improve
anything beyond this they're sort of
strictly ordered in terms of being the
more critical dependencies if you don't
fix them you don't get to move to
improve the performance no so the y axis
of this plot is
measuring latency once my party has
started executing true yep so I have a
comment about this great so I'm Ferris
my god am I give you another at the end
of the day the users most likely as a
learning about the entrance latency of
the entire operation part of that it has
to do with the queuing delay involved in
the server and now that you are
analyzing your individual transactions
as which is that the curricle a cell the
waiting time that leads up to my being
dispatched to the small people ship
might get higher and as a result of the
reasonable load right this way and that
love making a big difference like they
you will make this work yeah so the 1i
big caveat for I think for interpreting
this work is there actually are
legitimate arguments you can make about
why you may not like this feature all
the time certainly in it in a real
database system if you were run if you
if you did have enough transactions to
keep the entire system busy there's
certainly no reason to turn this on you
would only want to turn this on if you
actually had idle resources and you're
willing to pay the power cost of turning
them on so but yeah yeah so you have to
keep that in mind you don't want to
saturate the system and make other you
don't want to make non-spec ative work
slower by doing this or it will hurt
throughput and potentially even latency
but but the other way that I like to
look at it is just you can pretend that
this isn't a database system just take a
transaction and say well this is just
ignore what it's doing its this is a
pretty complicated piece of software and
we managed to make it run a lot faster
it's very bursty yeah that's my
impression so sometimes they are
saturated but most of the time they're
not saturated it's very bursty so you
want to monitor how the bursts and not
turn this off during a burst probably
it's easy to turn this off you can turn
it off in like one instruction so how
much how much does your programmer need
to worry hey about the underlying
microarchitecture versus just the code
and so for example Paul sharing of the
example where yeah hardware details and
then be obvious about the specifics of
the speculative threading protocol ok
well yeah file sharing was the really
the only one we need to know anything
about the memory system you need and in
this case so other than that there
weren't any other like system parameters
that you would need to know other than
that like your ability to buffer threads
you would want to realize that you
shouldn't make threads that are way
larger than your system's ability to
buffer things but we never actually
thought about it we just tried to design
something I mean we just used the second
well I'll talk later about the hardware
support for this and why we can buffer
enough state but yeah you in when Chris
did this he wasn't thinking at all about
any system parameters he just realized
that oh that's not parallel code I could
make that parallel code by doing this
little thing but and the key thing that
I probably didn't emphasize is the
reason why this works so well and you
can do it so quickly is that you don't
have to actually go off and understand
all of the code when you make one of
these changes you can just zoom in on
this specific thing you're working on
change it and you can still have lots of
other problems going on in fact there
are there even as he's doing this
there's still dozens of dependences
sitting underneath this that are causing
things to so we never really get full
parallelism we get partial parallelism
things are somewhat overlapped and
that's why we get a speed-up of to as
opposed to four on four cores may be
possible to push it further but we
didn't work on that
okay so at this point we actually can't
improve this much more because the only
part of execution time that gets better
with less better speculation is this
violation time and that's already fairly
small the reason why we aren't running
faster is that the number of iterations
in this loop isn't very large so we just
don't have enough parallel work to keep
all the cores busy in many cases so
that's really the bottleneck we tried an
artificial experiment where we just
increase the number of iterations
artificially and we got much better
speed up but that's what you would
expect and again important part is it
took Chris 30 days of effort and he
change less than twelve hundred lines of
code out of 200,000 and you never and he
didn't understand the application and
didn't really know I mean I don't make
sound like he's not a bright guy or
something he's very bright guy but you
don't need to be an expert on this to
get this kind of improvement so we
looked at the other new order is one of
the five transactions in TP CC we did
the same process to the other for two of
them sped up very nicely even more than
new order so delivery is running and
we've eliminated two thirds of the
execution time here and stock levels
running more than twice as fast the
other two cases did not read not improve
and in these cases there there weren't
loops and there were a lot of
dependences we couldn't find any obvious
way to break them into smaller chunks so
this doesn't always work but it worked
well in these three cases ok so for for
a database type audience the conclusions
from this are that we we found this new
form of parallelism we can now break up
transactions at different chunks we did
have to change the database management
system but it didn't take very much
effort to do that and we think this
could be applied to more than
transactions not only within databases
but other types of peace other types of
software okay so that's the the main
part of the talk I've got another yep
little part
use your power
okay so I mean you just have to decide
what your preferences were if you are
incredibly stingy about energy you don't
then don't speculate but but then
relative to your preference for latency
I mean improving performance so there's
a trade-off there and you always have to
decide how much you care about one thing
versus the other thing so this is a way
to make it run faster but without this
it's not obvious to me at least how you
would make transactions run faster
because they're not concurrent and clock
rates aren't getting any faster yep
because to have to improve the
performance under speculative case great
but when you turn speculation arm off
how much do you pay for this extra
instruction so if you really want to
have a peek for example and you don't
want to have Stickley
ah let's see so well you can figure that
out actually by just looking at the
height of the blue bar this is the
software overhead shows up in this blue
section it's actually increasing a
little bit but it's only a couple
percent so you're not you're not paying
very much so the leo yeah the like yeah
that's basic answer yep that's your ear
after view apparel is my single clients
yes did Chris looking at increased
number of class is TPC has lots of sleep
times as your increased number of
clients what's means by the weather you
can still be speculating and performance
transaction from local client
we didn't look at that that would be
interesting to look at but we we didn't
do that yep oh um we did not do that
know that I would I don't yeah I don't
know what the answer would be I believe
that the things that we did here are all
the nice thing is they're all generally
useful I think so after what I didn't I
didn't make this clear but what Chris
did is he started with new order and he
made these improvements and then he
simply ran these cases without changing
the database at further database
management system so the fixes for new
order are also very useful for these two
cases he didn't there weren't any other
bottlenecks he had to fix so I don't
know I've t PCH how it would stress the
database management system but there's a
decent chance that that the improvements
here would be useful for it I mean they
have much longer running queries so in a
sense part of the reason why we didn't
do it is because the intra query
parallelism work so well generally that
we were we didn't think it was as
interesting but it it there's no reason
not to try it so that would be another
experiment to do okay so the second part
of the talk oh just go through this
quickly but I was this is about how what
we learned about changing the underlying
design of the system to make this work
so I really know that the majority of
you aren't architects but you might find
this a little bit interesting perhaps so
okay so we have to buffer large
speculative threads and we have to deal
with sub thread so those are the main
two things so and when we were
paralyzing spec int our threads were
just typically tends to maybe hundreds
maybe thousands or so instructions long
we're just paralyzing loops in C code so
those typically aren't lupa to rate
individual iterations typically aren't
that big but here our loops are thread
sizes even though we're paralyzing a
loop again it's a loop in sequel and
beneath that is
database management system engine that's
voguing lots of lots of other code so
that turns into tens of thousands of
instructions in delivery it was almost
half a million instructions and this is
the number of dynamic data dependences
on average between those threads so you
know these are 75 or tens of dependences
so we start off with 75 and he fixed
about a dozen of them so there are still
about 60 or so dependences still there
that he didn't fix but they just
happened to be less critical and we
could get some performance improvement
so one of the challenges is we have to
buffer larger threads and well so
there's some related work here the big
difference is in our original design we
buffered everything in the first level
caches and now we realize we have to
start buffering a deeper in the memory
hierarchy we had to buffer the second
level cache is this involved adding
another bit to our first level cache to
keep track of some extra state and
adding a few bits to the tags of our
second level caches also when there are
collisions an interesting thing that
happens is when you're physically
sharing the cash and different threads
are writing two different copies of
things you end up with different
versions of something so what we did is
to we would actually allow replication
within a set associative cache so that
was another change and we added a small
victim cache just in case we had some
pathologically bad cash mapping so those
are the things we did to buffer larger
threads and that worked that worked well
and then we also had to support sub
threads so the only trick for supporting
sub threads is we already have external
to the cash we have these epoch numbers
these are logical timestamps they sit on
the side because they're only a handful
of them that are active at a time for
the whole cache get stuck
no checkpoints yes if there's how we
implemented incremental checkpointing
all we had to do was add support for
some more virtual time stamps because
the trick is you just bump the time
stamp number that's all you have to do
that takes no time basically just adds a
few more bits to the tags another
interesting another question that we
thought might be something we thought
might be an interesting a research
question was when do we create where do
we take the check points so the our
intuition was the optimal answer would
be that you would take a check if let's
say that this was what our code look
like and we're going to have a
dependence violation here the optimal
thing would be to take a check point
just before a very risky load one that's
likely to fail so we thought maybe we
end up need to build some predictor to
predict which are the risky loads and
take the check point just before them
and we're excited to write a paper on
this brilliant idea but then we
discovered that actually just suing
doing something very simple minded works
quite well if you just take a checkpoint
every 5,000 instructions it works really
well just as well as this okay so here
are some results here so going back to
New oh these are all the different
things plus this artificial version of
new order where we increase the number
of iterations by a factor of 10 now this
is not the number i showed you before
this is what the world would look like
if we did not have our checkpointing
support so remember new order was
running twice as fast before and now
it's it's running faster but not nearly
as fast delivery was running three times
faster and now it's only running a
little bit faster oh sorry this delivery
outer was running three times faster
over here these are two different
versions of that so sub threads are
important and if we had no if we had no
dependence violations if this was
perfect we would only get the bars on
the right so the checkpointing allowed
us to cover much of the distance between
the baseline case and the perfect case
there's not a huge amount of room for
further improvement okay
that's important and sub threads didn't
actually affect the cache performance so
not that we would expect it to affect it
very much do you have a violation which
ends up rolling back speculative thread
to you know a large number of what you
call separate or checkpoints you expect
cor performance gap between data and new
hands five issues and so what you're
saying here is that yeah that's there
that's shows up of this red the red part
in the middle bar yep is that time yeah
with this technique I was all the time
the only real back a very small number
of sub threads it was really you know
sort of so this idea we discussed today
doing selected replay only replaying the
stuff that hasn't changed in terms of
data I wouldn't really be all that
useful because they're not very much
more yet yes that's right yeah the
difference between the height of the red
bars is where we've got here actually in
some cases it didn't help very much and
well these cases are never a good on the
right but in these cases yeah there's
not much to get in these cases we've
gotten much of what there is to get so
it
gee I have to remember I have to look it
up is something like 48 just just
affects you just multiply that number by
2 and that's the number of bits you have
in the cache tag that's the cost of it
no we oh let me let's see let's see how
did we do that I forget the answer that
I'll have to look that up after the talk
i know we have I know that we did that
properly right yeah I have to I don't
remember the answer that I remember we I
remember discussing that and I forget
what the answer is I'll look it up at
the end of the talk but I don't remember
off the top of my head how we did that I
remember how we did it generally but I
don't I know we didn't do it that way
here okay so we had we had a victim
cache and know how how how the question
here is how large where the victim cache
need to be with different amounts of
associativity in a second level cache to
capture everything that ever gets
evicted this is a one megabyte l2 cache
and so if you have just a 4-way set
associative cache you need you know
dozens of entries here if it's eight or
sixteen way then you don't need very
many entries so it can be relatively
small and work this graph is you're
showing the size of the sub threads with
a fixed size starting from 250 dynamic
instructions going at the tune or 25,000
and the sweet spot happens to be at
around 5,000 for some reason so if you
make this too small the trade-off is you
end up using up all of your checkpoints
early on on the thread and then you run
for a long time and you can't check
point anymore if you make them too large
then you have to go back further to get
to a checkpoint so given how you know
given just the particular sizes of our
threads and where the dependences were
occurring this is where it was happening
you can easily imagine changing this
dynamically this is just something in
the hardware that it decides how often
to do this so this could be dynamically
adjusted
were all of your this is a case where
microarchitecture the size of the l2
would be something that the programmer
really had to do if you are going to do
some sort of automatic adaptation of the
sub thread size or in other words
pulling at around if I supported a
certain sub thread size in Hardware the
programmer would need to reason about
that before choosing the size of the
specular threads yeah what I think you
what I think would work well we didn't
bother to do this is if if the hardware
just tracked maybe after the first
iteration the dynamic size of each
thread and just divided that evenly
between the number of checkpoints that
you have I think that would work well
probably pretty well and it turned out
that with 5,000 instructions for
checkpoint and I think we had maybe
eight checkpoints that was you know
enough instructions that you got 40,000
into the thread and that was you gained
enough with that that everything was
good question points kind of so if you
do brother of checkpoints and then you
throw up throw away the first one and
stick it on the end I'd have to go back
and think about that I think there may
have been a reason why that wouldn't
have worked why that would have been
painful to implement but it seems like a
good idea I mean if other than the input
other than being some detail in our
design why that would be hard to do it
would make a lot of sense to just sort
of exponentially back off the
checkpoints and just keep more of them
more recently and fewer of them as you
get back in the past so that's probably
another good improvement on this but it
was already working well enough that oh
yeah these are number of sub threats so
oh here we go to foreign aid sub threads
so we found that it was working well
enough that you know it seemed like
there wasn't that much to gain by being
fancier than we were being so okay so
from you know um my last two slides here
so for an architecture audience what we
learned our that that these lightweight
checkpoints or sub threads are important
to get speed up in cases where there are
a lot of dependences between the threads
the fact that we get this feedback about
the critical dependence is important
because that allows the programmer to
iteratively fix things now the reason
why I mention that is it's possible to
build TLS and not make this visible to
software and this is something that we
would want hardware people who make
visible to software because if you don't
do that you're losing a big opportunity
to improve your code in fact I might
even argue that even if TLS didn't
functionally work if you simply profile
this and made that visible to the
software to the programmer that would be
very interesting information it would
tell you just dynamically what is going
wrong when I would if I tried to run
this in parallel so we found a way to
deal with large threads and this is a
pretty simple set of extensions to
existing design so final slide so I
think we got a fairly compelling amount
of speed up on a large piece of software
and with a fairly small amount of effort
and basically what we need our sub
threads and this feedback that i just
mentioned so there's hope for dusty deck
codes on multicore without having to
invest you know years of time to go back
and rewrite something from scratch so if
you like this idea you might want to
mention it to your friends at intel or
AMD hint hint yes I'd be happy to don't
you have eyes until I consult for Intel
so I'd be happy to introduce you the
right people yes wealthy socket system
would you be able to create a
speculative Timo Perez that spend more
than one chip yeah actually are just we
had a paper in iska several years ago
showing exactly that so we can we
designed our support so that it the chip
boundaries didn't mean anything so it
just it just worked on top of coherence
and coherence can be implemented
recursively and it'll just work on any
scale of system now the only thing that
limits that being interesting is how
much speed up you get so there are cases
where you can get interesting speed up
across multiple trips where it's
speculating across the whole thing but
do anything special with in-flight
messages
no you just need to atomically this when
you what there's a point there's a
logical timestamp when a thread is
executing it has a logical timestamp and
the trick that we're doing is we're just
bumping its logical timestamp so we we
give it a range of time stamps that are
contiguous and we say okay now you're
the first one a second one so next one
all you need to do is make sure that you
atomically change that with respect to
any cash actions so you the messages can
still be coming in is you need to just
hold them off for a minute while you
change the count and then let it proceed
and then everything should be okay
anyway Oh using simulation yes nice come
back already so it probably didn't have
plans to implement it in our way all
refugees or something but do you think
that the situation might change
when you implement if you will hardware
like I don't know adding netting bits to
the cash might be a problem in hardware
because size increases latest increases
and that it might be may look like a
good idea song where simulation where
you know it's cheap but you know yeah so
I don't think I don't believe our cell C
I don't believe the absolute performance
of our simulator but we try tried
actually wrote a lot of the initial part
of the simulator and we tried to design
everything so that whenever we were
cutting corners on something that we
didn't think it would change any of the
relative performance gains of anything
that's why I always present normalized
execution time because i think the the
ballpark speed up improvement is i do
believe that you know plus or minus five
percent or whatever so i wouldn't expect
it to suddenly be the case that this was
slowing down a lot rather than speeding
up a lot in terms of the you know the
first going from like you know the bar
where we slowed down a little bit in our
initial whoops that's not so it's back
here so like in terms of how much is
this flow down I don't know exactly you
know it could very well be were worse
than that because we didn't model the
extra latency to the primary cash
because we had more bits in it or
something like that so the that's
something there are things that we
didn't model
you